nous poursuivons avec l'examen du projet
de loi relatif à la régulation et à la
protection de l'accès aux oeuvres
culturelles à l'ère numérique en
accueillant monsieur roch olivier
maistre président du du csa monsieur le
président le nouveau projet n'a pas
l'ampleur que nous aurions souhaité
comme j'ai pu l'indiquer nous l'avons
nous avons pu l'indiquer la ministre il
y à quelques minutes mais il n'en marque
pas moins une étape essentielle pour le
conseil supérieur engagé dans une fusion
avec l'hadopi cette fusion et pour
objectif d'améliorer la lutte contre le
piratage des oeuvres un phénomène qui
prive les détenteurs de droits de
plusieurs milliards d'euros de revenus
chaque année l'institution que vous
présidez déjà chargé de lourde mission
de viendra demain avec l'adoption de ce
texte le grand régulateur du numérique
parachevant un mouvement amorcé avec la
loi sur les fausses informations aux de
la force est de reconnaître que le
projet de loi modifie assez peu les
conditions de lutte contre le piratage
avec la seule adjonction de deux
dispositifs que son l'établissement
d'une liste noire et la possibilité de
blocage des sites miroirs la réponse
graduée elle même ne bénéficient que
d'évolutions à la marge
alors même que son efficacité est
régulièrement décriée
monsieur le président notre commission
et donc impatients de vous entendre sur
ce projet de loi à la fois sur les
conditions concrètes de la fusion mais
également sur le nouveau cadre juridique
de lutte contre le piratage des oeuvres
qui sera incarné par l'art comme je vous
cède donc la parole pour une
intervention liminaire à l'issue de
laquelle notre rapporteur sur le texte
jean raymond hugonnet vous posera une
première série de questions et je ne
doute pas que mes collègues présents ou
derrière leur écran auront aussi des
questions à vous poser je rappelle enfin
avant de vous donner la parole que cette
audition ait capté et diffusé en direct
sur le site du sénat
ce président merci monsieur le président
de votre accueil merci aux membres de la
commission de me permettre
de m'exprimer sur ce texte cet après
midi toujours avec joie qu'on retrouve
votre commission laquelle nous
échangeons beaucoup ou tenu de
l'intensité de vos travaux sur les sur
les sujets qui nous réunissent lors ma
dernière audition devant votre
commission mois de décembre j'avais
pointé devant vous la nécessité de
procéder à des évolutions législatives
en évoquant notamment le rapprochement
entre le conseil et et l'hadopi ainsi
que la modernisation de la de la lutte
contre le piratage
deux évolutions qui seront évoqués de
longue date maintenant au sein de votre
commission est de notre côté par la voix
de notre collège il faut donc se réjouir
de voir ces deux projets de loi inscrits
aujourd'hui à l'ordre du jour du sénat
ils figureront probablement parmi les
derniers textes de la législature
on peut penser je voudrais donc
remercier ici toutes celles et tous ceux
qui ont contribué à la naissance de
cette taxe tu sur lesquels le conseil
vous le savez a émis un avis favorable
le 22 mars dernier
si vous permettez dans un premier temps
j'évoquerai les avancées que
représentent ces textes du point de vue
du conseil et dans un second temps
j'évoquerai des points qui à nos yeux
restent encore en suspens et sur lequel
il serait bon que l'on puisse avancer si
le législateur ou en ont décidé ainsi
alors l'une des principales avancées du
tac je l'avais dit monsieur le président
réside naturellement dans la création de
la nouvelle autorité de régulation de la
communication audiovisuelle et numérique
l'art comme ce rapprochement du csa et
l'hadopi représente bien plus qu'un
simple changement de sigle c'est bien
plus qu'un simple exercice de mécano
administratif il s'agit de constituer
avec cette réforme
un régulateur intégrés qu'ils soient
compétents sur l'ensemble de la chaîne
de la création depuis les obligations
imposées
au diffuseur jusqu'à la protection des
droits de propriété intellectuelle et
notamment les droits d auteur il existe
ça je tiens à le souligner dans votre
commission vous le savez bien une réelle
continuité entre les missions
historiques du csa de soutien à la
création de visuels cinématographiques
et musicales
un des volets importants de nos de nos
missions une vraie continuité donc entre
ses missions du csa et des missions de
lutte contre le piratage et de promotion
de l'offre légale qui sont celles de
l'hadopi des missions de lutte contre le
piratage que le projet de loi ordinaire
prévoit par ailleurs à juste titre de
moderniser et de renforcer sur ce point
donc je le redis devant votre commission
cet après midi le conseil a renvoyé dans
son avis aux observations de l'hadopi
tout le volet piratage stricto sensu
normal que ce soit l'hadopi qui
s'expriment puisque c'est l'autorité
compétente mais je veux dire néanmoins
devant vous nous partageons pleinement
cet objectif d'actualisation de notre
législation rendu d'autant plus
nécessaire par les effets de la crise
sanitaire
cette rénovation attendue des outils de
lutte contre le piratage
s'ajoutera aux nombreuses évolutions
législatives réglementaires en cours
je voudrais souligner devant votre
commission le l'intensité de l'actualité
législative intéressant le conseil
depuis depuis deux ans environ je pense
à la transposition de la directive à ses
marques pas le plus petit morceau que
nous allons déployer cette année en
conventionnel
les acteurs concernés je pense aux
textes encore en examen au parlement
de loi séparatiste quel que le sénat
l'occasion d'examiner qui nous intéresse
également directement en particulier en
matière de lutte contre la haine en
ligne mais je pourrais citer aussi le
projet de loi qui lui aussi en cours
d'examen devant parlement portant lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique et
renforcement de la résilience face à ces
effets qui lui aussi nous attribue de
nouvelles compétences
donc c'est une autorité dont le
périmètre n'aura cessé de s'étendre au
cours des deux dernières années le
collège sur la composition duquel nous
avons par ailleurs souhaité formuler
vous l'avez vu dans notre avis quelques
quelques observations ainsi que les
équipes de la future art comme auront
bien sûr à coeur de concrétiser toutes
ces transformations en cours de la
régulation audiovisuelle et numérique
je les dis elles se sont accélérées ces
dernières années vont se multiplier
encore cette année pour ce faire l'art
comme disposera de pouvoirs d'enquêté
renforcée en ce qu une autorité qui sera
je crois aux meilleurs standards d
autorité publique indépendante mais
aussi du cirad un dispositif de sanction
révisé et je crois juste titre et vise à
nous avions assisté nous mêmes sur ce
point pour garantir l'effectivité et le
caractère dissuasif à l'égard en
particulier de tout ce qui touche au
financement de la de la création pour
votre bonne information donc depuis un
an les deux autorités se sont pleinement
engagés malgré des incertitudes sur le
calendrier législatives dans ce projet
de fusion
nous avons commencé dès janvier 2020 le
travail de préfiguration dans le cadre
d'une convention conclue entre nos deux
autorités et je souhaite remercier
devant vous le président devenir apple
est la présidente par intérim mme annick
zerbib ainsi que l'ensemble des équipes
de l'hadopi pour l'engagement dans ce
projet et les deux maisons
incontestablement appris à se connaître
et à travailler ensemble
les échanges entre nos équipes se sont
multipliés ces derniers mois une bonne
dynamique de travail en commun a émergé
avec des résultats tout à fait stimulant
je vous signale si vous avez l'occasion
encore de de la consulter l'étude
conjointe que nous venons publiés le
mois dernier sur la vidéo à la demande
par abonnement
un sujet pleinement pleinement
d'actualité on a vu que ce travail
conjoint des deux autorités permettait
de produire un document je crois qu'il
ya beaucoup intéresser tous les acteurs
concernés
il ne faut pas se cacher toutefois là
aussi je souhaite souligner ce point
malgré ma ma condition de magistrats des
comptes que cette fusion aura aussi des
conséquences budgétaires sur lesquels
nous avons attiré l'attention du
gouvernement
je profite de cette audition pour
appeler l'attention du sénat
je rappelle que depuis plusieurs années
les missions du conseil s'accroît gelé
rappelé alors que sa dotation budgétaire
elle a décru légèrement et face à cet
effet de ciseaux
les efforts de gestion jusqu'à présent
permis de dégager des marges et les
ressources nécessaires mais je veux le
dire ici
cette logique n'aura qu'un temps il ya
là à notre sens un vrai point
d'attention pour pour l'avenir si on
veut que l'autorité soit au rendez vous
et ils répondent pleinement aux attentes
du législateur
ce qui me conduit et c'est le second
point je voulais aborder devant vous cet
après midi ou aux autres chantiers qui à
notre sens restent à mener à bien sur le
plan législatif si le parlement une fois
encore en décide ainsi je pense d'abord
venant serais pas surpris à la
modernisation de la plateforme tnt il
existe aujourd'hui une complémentarité
de différents modes d'accès à la
télévision de l'iptv à l'hôte était en
passant par le par le satellite
mais il ne faudrait pas oublier je le
rappelle constamment que plus d'un foyer
sur cinq utilise aujourd'hui que la tnt
pour la télévision grâce aux obligations
de couverture la tnt je rappel touche
plus de 95% de la population y compris
en zone
rural et donc indépendamment du
déploiement indispensable est en cours
de la route de la fibre le conseil en
tant que régulateur sectoriel très
attentifs au devenir de la plateforme
tnt il en va d'une égalité de traitement
entre entre nos concitoyens
notre préoccupation en la matière c'est
d'éviter un décrochage technologique de
cette plateforme et les jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de 2024 ouvre des
perspectives intéressantes bien
notamment pour développer l' ultra haute
définition mais également
l'interactivité on aura peut être
l'occasion d'en parler
vous avez peut-être notre tête nous
venons d'autoriser deux expérimentations
la matière au bénéfice d'un art et d'une
part et de la plateforme salto d'autre
part on a formulé donc sur cette
question la modernisation de la
plateforme 100 des propositions
concrètes dans notre avis afin qu'on ne
manque pas l'opportunité que représente
ce projet de loi si on rate cette
échéance il faut avoir conscience sera
en grande difficulté pour réaliser
l'ultra haute définition à l'échéance de
2024 un autre point que nous avons
souhaité mettre en avant dans notre dans
notre avis la situation du secteur des
radios d'un secteur qui a été touché par
la crise sanitaire
on se réjouit de la publication dimanche
dernier du décret instituant une aide
exceptionnelle à la diffusion hertzienne
c'est un texte qui était très attendue
dès le printemps dernier y compris
devant votre commission le conseil
fortement insisté pour que des mesures
de ce type soient soient prises pour
redonner de l'oxygène à ce secteur je
pense notamment à tout le tissu des
réseaux radios associatives qui est très
important dans notre dans notre pays
mais au delà le média radio c'est en
tant d'autres préoccupations je pense
par exemple à la demande d'
assouplissement du régime des mentions
légales en matière de publicité
radiophonique
ces mentions légales qui finissent par
occuper plus d'espacé que le message
publicitaire lui même
c'est un dispositif qui du coup est très
pénalisant pour le média radio
nous avons évoqué également dans notre
avis une autre question qui méritera
d'être examinés qui est celle de la
diversité musicale sur les grandes
plateformes de streaming audio car vous
savez aujourd'hui que seuls les radios
sont soumises à un régime d'obligations
à ce titre ce qu'on appelle les quotas
de chansons françaises notamment alors
que bien évidemment les plateformes de
streaming sont libres de tout de toute
obligation il ya là une asymétrie qui
gagnera être corrigé enfin le dernier
chantier le plus ample mais peut-être
aussi le plus nécessaires à moyen et
long terme concerne notre dispositif
sectorielle en ti concentration est la
présidente de silva a eu l'occasion de
l'évoquer la semaine dernière devant
votre votre commission chacun constate
que le dispositif prévu par la loi de
1986 a été dessiné une époque où le
paysage était radicalement différent de
ce qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est un
dispositif dont les règles concernent
que la diffusion hertzienne
or on sait la diffusion se fait par bien
d'autres canaux qui ne sont pas soumis
aux mêmes aux mêmes obligations
sur ce point je voudrais vous faire part
de ma conviction personnelle c'est le
self du collège également bien sûr c'est
il serait prônant illusoire de penser
que les seules règles du droit de la
delà de la concurrence règle la question
il y a une spécificité liée au domaine
qui est le nôtre
un domaine qui touche aux libertés
publiques l'objectif de pluralisme qui
est au fondement de la loi de 1986 c'est
un objectif qui découle des exigences
constitutionnelles principe est un
principe rappelé régulièrement par par
le conseil constitutionnel et donc il
n'est pas anormal qu'il y ait des
mécanismes sectoriels qui soit adaptée
aux particularités du secteur mais tout
aussi clair que des actualisations
s'impose il nous semble par exemple
qu'on viendrait probablement de donner
une place plus importante à la prise en
compte de l'audience des médias qui ont
de fortes audiences et qui ont donc un
impact sur l'opinion publique
beaucoup plus fort que d'autres qui ont
des audiences nîmes et d'actualiser les
dispositifs actuels qui sont fondées
essentiellement sur des critères
arithmétique de calcul de couverture de
la population savait et esquisser
l'année dernière lorsque le précédent
projet de loi est examiné par
l'assemblée nationale par la commission
des affaires culturelles de l'assemblée
nationale
mais ce point n'a pas n'a pas abouti
comme vous le savez et au delà peut-être
à plus long terme nous avons appelé à un
réexamen dansant du dispositif soit
transformations en cours
notre notre suggestion c'est la
proposition que nous avions fait au
gouvernement serait de confier une
mission à des experts pour bien balayer
ces questions qui sont complexes il faut
le reconnaître c'est pas des sujets à
enjeu politique mais en même temps
compliquée techniquement et donc cette
piste nous semble rester d'actualité
voilà les quelques mots que je voulais
prononcé devant vous en introduction je
me tiens naturellement à la disposition
des sénatrices et sénateurs pour
répondre à vos questions
merci monsieur le président une première
question vous revenir du rapporteur jean
raymond y donner merci président m'a
trois questions président en vous
réitérant le plaisir de vous avoir à nos
côtés au sénat la première touchera à la
composition de l'art comme dans votre
avis vous avez émis des doutes sur
l'intérêt de prévoir la présence de deux
magistrats en lieu et place de deux
personnalités nommées par le parlement
que penseriez-vous de maintenir la
composition actuelle du csa pour le
collège de l'art comme et de prévoir que
cette dernière doit désigner parmi ses
membres ayant une compétence juridique
celui qui aura la charge de mettre en
oeuvre la réponse graduée
la seconde question touche à l'avenir de
la plateforme tnt vous l'avez rappelé un
français sur cinq
ici l assemblée d dans l'assemblée des
territoires nous sommes particulièrement
vigilants à haslam et aujourd'hui
plusieurs chaînes historiques
réfléchissent à la quitter
cette tnt pour échapper à ces
contraintes réglementaires n'est-il pas
temps de dépoussiérer la loi de 1986 et
ne faut-il pas saisir l'opportunité de
ce projet de loi pour le faire je
donnerai deux exemples ne serait-il pas
opportun de permettre à l'art comme de
renouveler pour une seconde fois les
autorisations d'émettre des chaînes
historiques afin de prolonger d'autant
l'attractivité de la tnt ne faut-il pas
permettre aux chaînes de mieux maîtriser
les droits de la production qu'elle
finance est ainsi porté à 50% la part de
la production réalisée en interne ou
négociés de gré à gré avec les
producteurs indépendants pour leur
permettre de mieux concurrencer les
plateformes qui maîtrise totalement les
droits de leurs contenus
troisième et dernière question porte sur
l'évolution relativement minime de la
réponse graduée que le projet de loi ne
fait évoluer qu'à la marge et uniquement
sur les aspects de procédure beaucoup
auraient souhaité étendre plus encore
les pouvoirs du régulateur notamment par
l'institution d'une transaction pénale
établi par l'art comme pour éteindre
l'action publique
que penseriez-vous d'introduire cette
évolution dans le projet du roure merci
pour vos réponses et dont je vais vous
laisser répondre à cette première série
de questions puis après il y aura une
deuxième série
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur
notre première question sur la la
composition dollar comme l'or le conseil
a formulé plusieurs observations vous
l'avez vous l'avez rappelé donc je
voudrais rappeler le le sens la première
observation a trait aux effectifs du
collage
il ya eu il ya eu plusieurs plusieurs
navettes avec le gouvernement sur ce
projet de loi que vous pouvez l'imaginer
plusieurs plusieurs pistes de rédaction
avait envisagé l'un des points sur
lequel nous avons beaucoup insisté sur
lequel j'ai personnellement beaucoup
insisté c'est de rester un effectif de
sept membres au sein de ce collège vous
avec l'histoire de la régulation
maintenant ancienne qu'on a connu
plusieurs institutions on a connu des
effectifs au sein de ces institutions à
géométrie variable si je puis dire
on a fini par se stabiliser depuis
quelques années à l'effectif de 2,7
c'est je crois le bon chiffre s'est
taillé idoine pour asseoir une bonne
collégialité que la chine une
collégialité efficace avec une bonne
répartition du travail et ayant
privilège de l'âge l'histoire de
l'institution montre qu'avec des
effectifs plus importants
les délibérations de cette institution
n'était pas toujours placée sous le
signe de la même efficacité
donc on a beaucoup insisté sur ce point
là alors le projet de loi tel qu'il est
rédigé prévoit que nous serions
l'effectif du collège serait porté à
neuf de façon transitoire en 2022 mais
qu'il reviendrait à 7d le renouvellement
donc du début de l'année 2023 donc sept
premiers points en tout cas sur lequel
je me permets d'insister nous ne
souhaiterions pas que la taille du
collège soit soit modifié
particulier élargie de deuxième
observation c'est l'intérêt d'un collège
comme dirait monsieur de la palisse
c'est d'être un collège l'intérêt d'un
collège c'est la diversité de sa
composition
la diversité des profils la diversité
des origines en l'occurrence aussi la
diversité des autorités de nomination
c'est pas moi qui veut dire du mal des
juristes serait mal placé il ya des
juristes au sein du collège actuel nous
avons un conseiller d'état en la
personne de jean françois mary le
président du sénat a désigné à
l'occasion du renouvellement de cette
année l'ancienne directrice juridique de
l'autorité de la concurrence et une
juriste éminente je suis madame
magistrats comme comme vous le savez
donc ya pas il n'y a pas de position
bien évidemment la présence de deux
juristes au sein de ce collège et la loi
de 86 tel qu'il est rédigé pelle des
personnalités à raison dit la loi de
leurs compétences dans le domaine de la
communication mais aussi de leurs
compétences du juridique et les
présidents de l'assemblée et du sénat
ont régulièrement désigné deux des
personnalités ayant ce profil là pour
siéger au sein de au sein de
l'institution
mais il me semble important voilà de
veiller quand même à ce qu'on garde une
certaine une certaine diversité
du coup on avait un peu l'interrogation
sur la nécessité d'avoir deux magistrats
désignés pour cette compétence je
rappelle qu'actuellement la commission
de protection des droits de l'hadopi
les personnes qui agissent yann à temps
partiel alors que les membres du conseil
se faire de deux visuels d'un dollar
comme ce sont des personnes qui siègent
qui siège à temps complet donc voilà
voilà quel était le sens de nos
observations on a bien compris le souci
du gouvernement de de sécuriser
juridiquement l'institution regard des
compétences qui sont les siennes en
matière de lutte contre le piratage
d'une part ou sur des sujets touchant
aux libertés publiques
je pense à nos nouvelles compétences en
matière de lutte contre la haine on lit
les infos que peut-être demain la mise
en oeuvre du nouveau règlement européen
sur la responsabilité l'origine de
responsabilité de des plateformes donc
j'entends la proposition vous évoquez
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur
plongerait le naturellement la sagesse
du parlement
sur le deuxième point sur la plateforme
sur la plateforme tnt donc vous avez
bien compris le sens de nos de nos
observations sur les points que vous
vous soulevez monsieur le rapporteur
bon nous sommes nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans un cadrage juridique qui est très
très précis extrêmement précis même
[Musique]
perçu comme contraignant par par
certains ce que ce que je peux
comprendre sur les durées d'autorisation
et sur la procédure de renouvellement
des autorisations
vous avez entendu la semaine dernière
devant votre commission un acteur
important du secteur évoqué cette
question puisque lui-même l'entreprise
qu'il dirige
arrivant enfin d'autorisation est donc
le csa aujourd'hui fonctionne
obligatoirement dans ce cadre du
renouvellement avec une procédure qui
est assez lourde et longue puisque
grosso modo c'est celle qu'on a déployé
l'année dernière pour le renouvellement
de l'autorisation de canal+ c'est
pratiquement 18 mois de procédure
puisque on est tenu de faire une
consultation publique l'étude d'impact
lancé un appel à candidatures examiner
les candidatures auditionné pour choisir
le candidat retenu puis négocier la
convention avec le titulaire de
l'autorisation donc c'est vrai que c'est
une procédure qui est qui est lourde et
longue
alors l'éventualité de modifier la
législation sur ce point pour pourquoi
pas bon à ce stade l'argument qui a
toujours prévalu c'est celui de droit
européen ne rappeler que comme on est
sur une gestion de ressources publiques
re à une fréquence qui sont qui sont peu
nombreuses comme comme vous le savez le
paquet télécom dans la réglementation
européenne prévoit donc ses appels à
candidatures périodiques pour refaire
jouer refaire jouer la concurrence
si une expertise juridique permet
d'apporter une ouverture sur ce point
pourquoi pas je dirais et sur le
deuxième point je suis sensible à ce que
vous évoquez toutes les réformes qui
sont en cours doivent atteindre un
objectif qui est de tendre vers une
égalité de traitement entre les acteurs
c'est ce qu'on a essayé de faire avec la
transposition de la directive sm a en
faisant rentrer les nouveaux acteurs
dans le régime de financement de la
production et de la et de la création
alors ils participent peu aussi comme
les acteurs historiques au financement
de la production
c'est l'objet du décret 10 mad qui est
actuellement à l'examen du conseil
d'état sur lequel on s'est prononcée
nous mêmes il ya très peu de temps mais
il faut en parallèle le décret des
obligations qui vont s'appliquer aux
acteurs de la tête et le décret qui
fixera les obligations applicables aux
opérateurs qui fonctionne dans le cadre
du capsat soit soit homogène il faut pas
qu'on recrée une inégalité de situation
de l'un par rapport à l'autre et je
dirais qu'il ya d'autres paramètres qui
doit être pris en compte dans cet
équilibre d'ensemble qui est celui de
l'art de la chronologie des médias
surtout tout se tient donc dans cette
affaire-là si on veut que les acteurs
souhaitaient traiter de façon de façon
équilibrée alors le les discussions sont
en cours comme vous le savez sur ces
différents sujets vont les acteurs des
poids chacun leur leurs arguments je
crois qu'il faut laisser vraiment la
place à 7 à cette concertation avant que
le gouvernant puisque là on est dans le
domaine réglementaire une statue à
travers les décrets que que j'évoquais
mais j'insiste vraiment sur l'objectif
politique si je puis employé cette
expression de traitement homogène et
équilibrée des acteurs des acteurs entre
eux votre troisième question alors à
trop piratage mans je ne veux pas bien
évidemment il eu des votre question il
esquivé mais je redis ce que j'ai dit
dans mon propos liminaire donc on a
laissé le soin à hadopi de s'exprimer
sur tous les sujets piratage puisque
c'est l'autorité la plus la mieux placée
bien sûr pour pour évoquer et d'ailleurs
moi même pas eu l'occasion de mettre en
oeuvre la procédure de réponse graduée
jusqu'à présent ça va le faire
mais difficile de me prononcer sur son
évolution
mais quand même deux convictions très
fortes
1 la protection des droits et est
fondamental c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous mêmes csa on a beaucoup
insisté pour que les procédures et les
sanctions possibles en cas de non
respect des obligations de financement
de la production soit durci dans le
texte
ça je mettrai satisfait de ce point de
vue là que que le texte ait retenu ce
point et deuxième conviction c'est que
l'enjeu de la réforme dont nous
débattons cet après-midi de création de
cette nouvelle autorité
l'enjeu fondamental c'est de déployer
une nouvelle politique publique de lutte
contre le piratage qui déploie un
nouveau dynamisme en s'attaquant à la
source majeure du piratage que sont les
sites les sites illégaux
c'est vraiment c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut faire porter les efforts c'est
vraiment là qu'est la priorité si on
veut protéger de façon réellement
efficaces les droits le droit le droit d
auteur le cse mécanisme là qui
construira l'avenir de la lutte contre
le piratage c'est sur celui là qu'il
faut faire porter l'essentiel de nos
efforts
merci monsieur le président je vais
maintenant céder la parole aux sénatrice
et aux sénateurs qu'ils ont demandée jeu
là la liste comme ça chacun peut se
préparer
michel laugier david assouline jérémy
baky catherine morin desailly et laure
darcos échelle merci monsieur le
président en faisant de ses soeurs
toujours très heureux de vous accueillir
quelles que soient les fonctions qui
sont les votes gros fournis nous
rejoindre ici au sénat le juteux revient
sur le piratage même si j'ai bien
compris vous n'allez pas répondre à la
question mais je voulais préciser ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure à la ministre
qui a peut-être mal été compris
je disais qu actuellement avec le
confinement et avec les prix très élevés
des retransmissions télévisées
maintenant nous à nous arrivons bien sûr
un piratage renforcer dans douze qu'on
veut aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils aient plus
de boyen pour lutter contre le piratage
c'est exactement ce que j'ai des risques
qui a peut-être compris les choses dont
je préfère leur dire maintenant comme ça
les choses sont claires depuis la loi
sur les fausses informations de la loi
via le csa un rôle de régulateur
renforcer et je veux savoir ce que
l'organisation de votre institution et
les moyens qui vous sont données l'ont
été tout autant et ensuite je voudrais
aussi aborder un point sommes
actuellement le gouvernement et le
parlement peuvent saisir la hadopi
le texte de loi tel qu'il est présenté
ne le permet plus avec la fusion cs
hadopi alors ici au sénat en ce sens qu
au renouveau des saisies de de pouvoir
merci david astrid
oui bonjour monsieur le président
toujours aussi très heureux de pouvoir
vous écoutez de pouvoir vous vous posez
des questions sur un rôle très important
et justement qui va devenir encore plus
important avec les pouvoirs aux forces
et que vous donne cette fois
mesure pour laquelle j'ai toujours été
vous le savez depuis 2013 j'avais subi
des pressions gigantesque pour retirer
mon amendement qui proposait la fusion à
l'époque mais ça va dans le bon sens je
redis ce que j'ai dit à la ministre
je pense que si vous ne veux pas vous
mettre dans une mauvaise situation qui
serait d'avoir des pouvoirs accrus et
une capacité à les exercer réellement ce
qui rejaillirait sur vous alors que m
absolument pas responsables je pense
qu'il faudra tous veiller et nous en
votant le budget à ce que via les moyens
pour assumer cette nouvelle mission de
réguler aussi ce qui se passe sur le net
parce que c'est des moyens énormes parce
que ceux qui effectivement essayent de
contourner les règles sur le net on sait
qu'ils ont des moyens gigantesques et en
technologie en chercheur même au service
des contournements des lois et qu'il
faut des moyens que les états sont
souvent très peu outillés et que c'est
pour cela qu'ils ont toujours une fin de
retard et quand on a enfin compris
comment ont déjà pris d'avant sur
d'autres domaines et c'est une course
depuis bonn décennies
ou on est toujours en retard en tous les
cas ça va dans le bon sens ma première
question c'est sur la composition
moi je comprends tout notamment j'étais
plutôt pour la réduction du nombre parce
qu'on pouvait faire un set ce qu'on
faisait 1,9 à partir du moment où les
équilibres de représentation du
parlement restés les mêmes or là il ya
déséquilibre donc le président nomme le
président ok ça change pas les chambres
donnent leur avis ensuite on général
depuis le quinquennat la majorité
parlementaire de l'assemblée nationale
de la même couleur que le président donc
ça fait 4 donc ça fait 3 et puis il ya
deux qui viennent du sénat qui pourrait
être une autre connotation avec deux
magistrats qui quand même n'ont pas
vocation à être disons dans quelque
chose qui puisse déranger l executive
même si c'est pas aussi leur vocation
d'être dans quelque chose qui les
arrangent dans tous les cas il ya un
déséquilibre par rapport à dire dans
l'idée d'avant qui était que par le
parlement et sa pluralité politique
qu'il mène dans la façon dont le
parlement délibérer sur les nominations
il y avait la recherche qui est quand
même eu consensus dans ce set
indépendance des nominations je trouve
qu'un déséquilibre et comme
parlementaire qui subit depuis quelques
années disons une marginalisation du
parlement dans les décisions
tous les jours on le vit j'ai pas envie
d'accompagner sa alors bien entendu ça
voudrait dire que si je suis d'accord
que les deux magistrats que je propose
l'augmentation c'est à dire qu'on reste
à neuf et on garde un équilibre
je vais réfléchir d'ici les quelques
semaines qui nous séparent l'étude de la
loi mais en tous les cas je trouve qu'on
devrait tous un trouvé le moyen de faire
que de ne pas accepter cette diminution
du poids du parlement parce qu'on
partage sa hausse et naves tout bord
confondu
je voulais vous demander aussi donc
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
façon à cet aspect de la question vous
avez répondu sur l'autre ensuite je
pense d'abord je vais vous saluer pour
une sanction que vous avez prises qui
est à la hauteur de ce qui peut
dissuader
deux cent mille euros pour les propos
incitant à la haine d'eric zemmour sur
ses news
ces deux cent mille euros pour la chaîne
ça commence à compter
on va dire puisque ils s'en foutent 1-2
puis ça fait quand même
savez vous les avez souvent rappelée à
l'ordre il est condamné par la justice
pour ce genre de propos il continue donc
bravo mais je voudrais savoir si vous
pensez être un peu quand même empêché
tous les cas diminuer dans votre
capacité de réaction rapide pour des
sanctions lourdes
avec rethel de loi tel qu'ils existent
parce que j'ai bien envie moi de vous
donner ces moyens dans la loi d'agir un
peu plus vite quand de façon manifeste
il y à des atteintes au pacte
républicain au respect d'autrui et à
l'appel aux appels à la haine bien autre
chose d'ailleurs un cessez vos capacités
de sanctions comment faire en sorte que
ça ne l'est pas des années enfin comme
plus sacré des polémiques ont dit qu'est
ce que fait le csa alors c'est pas de
votre faute souvent bon donc je voulais
vous poser cette question là précise si
vous pensez que et qu'est ce que vous
pensez aussi
dernière question dans bon pour la vente
de catalogues
on sait très bien que ce qui nous est
présenté maintenant c'est quelque chose
de diminuer en termes de force par
rapport à ce qui était envisagé par le
gouvernement parce que le conseil d'état
jugé que ça pourrait contrevenir aux
règles européennes et à l'avis du
conseil d'état
ceci dit au diminuant la réponse en la
rendant molle elle devient pas très dans
tous les cas j'ai l'impression qu'elle
peut être contournée ou en tous les cas
diminuer dans sa plainte que est-ce que
vous pensez que d'abord de
l'autorisation pour les organismes de
gestion collective de pouvoir saisir le
csa général
qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait qu'on
pourrait faire que dans mon cas de vente
de catalogues et des entreprises
étrangères demandé à ce qu'un
pourcentage du prix de revente
reviennent aux cetc pour financer la
création ou demander un remboursement
des sommes investies par la puissance
publique a minima il y aurait du sens
pour dissuader et pour au moins avoir
retour côte
le vent on force on utilise nos trous
dans la raquette pour quand même bradé
le patrimoine cinématographique au bois
qui est un retour si on peut pas
l'empêcher rémy bas qui est derrière son
écran
je vais me merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président du csa j'aurais
simplement une question l'article
premier du projet de loi crée de
nouvelles compétences pour l'heure comme
établissement de liste noire de sites
contrevenants et moyens accrus pour
interrompre l'activité des sites dits
miroirs qui répliquent des sites même
déjà fermés
ces évolutions - incontestablement dans
le bon sens mais les termes actuels des
dispositifs sont très peu précis ce qui
donne au rapporteur indépendant du cnca
domaine de l'art comme et au collège une
grande latitude pour classifier les
sites
n'aimeriez vous pas nestea mariez-vous
pas pardon nécessaires pour votre
institution et par sécurité de prévoir
dans la loi l'édiction de lignes
directrices afin de bien encadrer ce
pouvoir et de les rendre plus clairs aux
yeux des parties prenantes je vous
remercie
catherine morin desailly que preen
collecte merci monsieur le président je
voulais tout d'abord saluer rang comme
lille et metz et toute l'équipe du csa
qui avait écrit fait un travail
absolument remarquable dans des temps où
les défis sont extrêmement nombreux et
où il faut en quelque sorte est sur tous
les fronts dire que je regrette que le
texte qui nous occupe est important au
demeurant ça finalement la réduction à
peau de chagrin à theix beaucoup plus
ambitieux et nécessaire était cette loi
audiovisuelle attendu et surtout annoncé
de très longue date d'ailleurs monsieur
le président vous avez vous en avait
énoncé indirectement les mots puisque
vous avez évoqué le chantier très
important de la modernisation de la tnt
ou peut-être tout à l'heure peut-être
juste quelques mots sur l'art comme je
voulais également salué le travail
remarquable de devenir un punk qui
malheureusement a dû
quitter le csa son mandat étant parvenue
à échéance et on peut d'ailleurs
regretter que la concomitance des
calendriers qui était à la fois à la fin
de son mandat et le moment où nous
devions luis ferrer n'est pas pu se
faire puisque tout était prévu pour le
mois de janvier occasionnant par
ailleurs par là même une transition qui
n'est peut-être pas forcément facile et
je voulais aussi les saluer pour les
conseillers de l'hadopi qui malgré tout
maintiennent de cet objectif important
de fusion avec le c est alors je
m'attarderai pas sur les questions de
nombre de conseillers que leur apportera
fort bien évoqué c'est un sujet qu'il
est approfondi par là par la commission
avec la vie de chacun je vais surtout
beaucoup insisté sur la nécessité
d'avoir de réguler sur le piratage on
sait le manque à gagner considérable
pour la création
ça représente chaque année une étude
d'ailleurs de l'hadopi de démontrer
encore il ya quelques quelques mois mais
je voulais plutôt m'attarder comme l'ont
fait mes collègues précédemment sur la
question des moyens
nous avons eu lors de la dernière loi de
finances un débat important sur les
moyens dédiés à la cnil
à lancy au csa en insistant beaucoup sur
le fait que la transition numérique les
nouveaux défis impose de se poser
sérieusement la question
si on veut légiférer correctement face
aux géants du numérique et à l'ensemble
des défis de la digitalisation on ne
peut pas faire l'économie d'une
réflexion alors est ce que vous pourriez
nous préciser premièrement quels sont
les métiers nouveaux ou les postes de
développeurs de techniciens qu'il est
absolument indispensable de créer est-ce
que vous pouvez nous apporter quelques
précisions par rapport à ses besoins en
moyens
pouvez-vous nous aussi nous établir une
comparaison ce qui se fait dans les
autres pays ce qui m'amène à peut-être
parler du travail remarquable que vous
faites au sein de les regards où en sont
les autres pays voisins en matière de
régulation sur ces sujets régulation
heureux au du visuel régulation voilà
des réseaux sont-ils doté de davantage
de moyens ou non peut-on se comparer
dans dans cette affaire alors il est
vrai que toutes les autorités de
régulation ne sont pas
pour la même configuration certaines ont
fusionné aussi avec ce qu'on appelle pas
recette dans d'autres pays
peut-être vous pouvez nous nous nous en
dire plus au delà de la question des
moyens
j'aurais voulu vous poser une question
également sur la con la concordance avec
le le travail remarquable que vous avez
fait de proposition pour le digital
services et isa est ce que tout ça est
réglé puisqu'il s'agit de la régulation
bien sûr des des plateformes et l'éco
système tel qu'il est construite
facilite forcément aussi toute forme de
cyberattaque dont le piratage finalement
fait répartis
et puis enfin dernière question
s'agissant de la tnt de chantier que
vous avez évoqué j'ai pour ma part tenu
absolument à déposer une proposition de
loi sur ce sujet qui peut être le moment
venu pour amender utilement le texte
mais je considère que c'est tout à fait
indispensable je m'étais appuyé sur
d'excellentes études peut-être
pourriez-vous nous en dire quelques mots
que le csa avait établi pour montrer que
il était nécessaire que le législateur
dote le régulateur de nouveaux outils
pour à la fois permettre de réaliser une
transition qui considère l'intérêt
général à l'ensemble des acteurs de
l'audiovisuel
mais répondre aussi nous attendait des
téléspectateurs afin d'améliorer la
qualité de la diffusion et vous l'avez
évoqué on a des défis comme les jeux
olympiques mais mais pas seulement
quels sont les autres avantages de la
tnt au delà de ce que vous avez évoqué
c'était la large couverture 97 % du
territoire
merci pour vos réponses à ces questions
et enfin l'or darcos merci monsieur le
président messieurs président pas vite
vous retrouvez jeu
je souscris tout ce qu'a dit mes
collègues moi j'avais deux questions
alors vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
vous laissiez à l'hadopi problème des
sanctions mais c'est vrai que j'aurais
bien aimé revenir quand même dessus et
notamment on va pas tourner autour du
pot de l'amendement d'aurore bergé qui
avait été déposé lors de la discussion
en commission à l'assemblée avant juste
avant la crise est ce que c'est juste le
terme de répression financière dans un
comme l'a dit la ministre dans un
contexte un peu particulier du coc vide
qui est qui est en cause est ce que
c'est la faisabilité de pouvoir
véritablement récupérer 7 7 cette
sanction je pars du principe que je
préfère que ce soit le vrai pirate qui a
conscience de pirater depuis des années
qui paye plutôt que tous les
contribuables
donc voilà c'est pour ça que je suis
assez en tout cas assez favorable mais
je voudrais savoir pourquoi est ce que
en termes de faisabilité
ça a l'air d'être compliqué je regrette
d'ailleurs à titre personnel qu'il n'y
ait plus ces spots de les visions
qu on avait juste avant les films je
sais pas pourquoi d'ailleurs ça a
disparu mais ça fait quand même une
vraie incidence fin moi je sais que
c'est comme ça que j'avais sensibilisé
monfils très très jeune même devant des
dessins animés au fait que pirater en
plus c'était assez violent comme comme
spot mais je trouve c'était bien donc si
on peut pas le faire soit pour une
répression financière au moins en termes
pédagogiques je trouve qu'il manque
énormément ce plan-là vis-à-vis de nos
jeunes et puis dans un tout autre
domaine à la fin de l'article 1
on parle de du fait de faciliter l'accès
aux personnes en situation de handicap
des oeuvres protégées par un droit
d'auteur et donc on serait recueillir
auprès des éditeurs de la biotech
nationale de france
les documents et informations est ce
qu'il s'agit des oeuvres en tant que tel
je vous dis ça parce que comme je déposé
une proposition de loi sur le livre et
qu'on a tout un volet dépôt légal
numérique
j'avais un moment donné hésité à mettre
l'aspect accessibilité et on sait qu'il
ya des problèmes de drm en fait très
important dans ces systèmes alors est ce
que c'est de ça qu'il s'agit et du coup
est ce que justement le volet dépôt
légal qui va être situé simon
propositions et est votée va vous aider
dans ce cadre là en tout cas
l'accessibilité aux personnes
handicapées bien évidemment c'est très
important
merci
laisser répondre à cette série qui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur loger je ne peux que souscrire
à ce que vous avez dit sur le
développement du piratage dans cette
période de confinement est également en
matière sportive sénateurs assouline
connaît très bien le très bien le sujet
nous venons nous mêmes de de rendre un
avis à l'autorité de la concurrence dans
le cadre de la plainte que canal+ a
déposé contre la ligue de football
professionnel sur les procédures d'appel
d'appels d'offres qui seront lancés par
par la ligue
on verra ce que décidera le l'autorité
mais on a là un vrai un vrai sujet comme
on dit ces deux sites c'est une spirale
en quelque sorte qui se traduit par un
système inflationnistes sur les droits
sur les droits sportifs les droits
télévisés qui a pour effet d'évincer
l'accès aux manifestations sportives en
clair ou en gratuit au profit des offres
payantes
on voit bien et l'étude à laquelle j'ai
fait allusion tout à l'heure qu'on a
conduite avec hadopi sur les plateformes
de vidéo par abonnement que le
consommateur a un budget moyen est qu'il
se tient à ce budget moyen ne cumule pas
à l'infi les abonnements on a on à sa
box on à son portable celui de ses
enfants
on a peut-être canal+ on va peut-être
netflix on a peut-être spotify mais il
ya un moment
un budget moyen et on le voit bien dans
les études qu'on a fait ce budget et
évolue assez peu la sphère média pro
elle a bien montré les limites de
l'exercice un moment quand vous faites
une offre à 25 euros
l'accès au match de foot la tentation du
piratage elle est extrêmement forte et
sur ces sujets-là sénateurs assouline
avait fait des propositions dans dans
son rapport
nous allons dans notre avis nous nous
appelons l'attention de l'autorité de la
concurrence et mais plus globalement
l'attention du gouvernement sur la
nécessité d'avoir une réflexion quand
même global sur ses procédures d'appel
d'appel d'offres des grandes fédérations
professionnelles qui vient impacter au
bout du compte une politique publique en
faveur du sport aussi donc on a on
aboutit à un système à la fois très
inflationniste très déstabilisant pour
les acteurs de l'audiovisuel mais aussi
déstabilisant pour le monde du sport
quand on voit la crise que vient de
traverser le football tout récemment
alors vous m'interrogez sur les moyens
et sur l'organisation de l'institution
je souhaite vraiment remercier toutes
les sénatrices et sénateurs qui se sont
exprimés sur le sujet très sensible à
l'attention que vous portez à cette
question sur l'organisation nous avons
entrepris le chantier de l'adaptation de
notre organisation nous avons créé il y
à il ya quelques semaines une nouvelle
direction au sein du csa que
l'appellation exactement de direction
des plates formes en ligne voit la
direction des plates formes en ligne qui
dit bien ce qu'elle veut dire donc qui a
pour mission de 2
de traiter plus particulièrement de la
régulation de ces plateformes ou titre
des nouvelles compétences qui nous ont
été données et puis surtout nous sommes
dans le travail de préfiguration en
cours avec hadopi dans une réflexion sur
un nouveau schéma d'organisation de
l'institution pour à la fois accueillir
au mieux les équipes d'adp aux pieds au
sein de au sein de notre institution
mais aussi et surtout mieux porter les
politiques publiques nous sont qui nous
sont confiés donc oui l'organisation de
l'art comme sera sera ajusté par rapport
à celle du csa plus qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui
et sur la question des moyens je je les
dis je ne pousse pas au crime bouclée
c'est mon tempérament et mon origine
professionnelle mais voilà là on arrive
à un moment où l'institution ne pourra
pas faire à budget constant là pour pour
deux raisons la première d'abord c'est
que la fusion elle même va générer un
certain nombre de coups chose assez
évidente il fallait refondre un site un
site internet il va falloir refondre
toute la charte graphique de
l'institution puisque on change de
niassa nombre de dépenses liées à
l'installation faire travailler sur le
sur les systèmes d'information pour
homogénéiser tout ça s'étale budgétaire
est contente donc les charges qui sont
liées qui sont liées à l'opération de
fusion elle-même stricto sensu
on essaye de faire en sorte qu'elle soit
le plus maîtrisé possible il y aura des
dépenses à ce titre et puis en rythme de
croisière pour bien porter ses missions
il faut qu'on monte en compétences sur
un certain nombre de domaines
tout ce qui a trait à ses grands acteurs
du numérique vous avez évoqué les uns et
les autres
ça suppose de savoir ce qu'est un
algorithme comment ils fonctionnent
comme on l'analyse comment décrypte ça
suppose de pouvoir faire de
de manier des données de masse pour
pouvoir les étudier les analyser on a
fait l'année dernière une étude sur la
diffusion de fausses informations sur
twitter bon voilà on a pu par un accord
avec twitter traiter des données de
masse mais ça suppose de savoir le faire
de voir le les compétences et le
savoir-faire requis donc voilà on va
avoir besoin de monter en compétence au
plan au plan technique qu'au plan
économique aussi parce que l'économie de
ces acteurs n'est pas la même que les
acteurs de l'audiovisuel history
juridique sociologique dans certains
domaines et à ce stade
ma jouer je vous donne un exemple de nos
limites financières et chacun comprendra
donc dans la loi de finances pour 2009 1
nous avions notre plafond d'emplois nous
allons été autorisés à le majoré de six
unités avec le seul inconvénient c'est
que la même loi de finances ne donnait
pas la masse salariale correspondante
donc c'est toujours très difficile de
recruter des salariés sans pouvoir les
rémunérer alors il se trouve qu'on a il
se trouve qu'on a pu faire l'année
dernière des efforts de gestion très
significatif grâce à la crise si j'ose
dire il ya de ça dont de dépenses sur
lesquelles on a pu faire des économies
puisqu'on s'est pas déplacé vraiment
bien voilà il ya des dépenses que qui on
a pu dégager un peu de marge et donc du
coup on va pouvoir financer cette année
sur nos propres ressources liées à ces
économies de l'année dernière ces six
postes supplémentaires qui vont
notamment venir consolider la direction
des plates formes en ligne que je viens
de que je viens d'évoquer
mais dès qu'on sera au rythme de
croisière il faudra bien que la masse
salariale correspondante pour pour ces
emplois et et ce dont nous allons nous
allons avoir avoir de juin donc oui nous
aurons besoin de moyens et je réponds à
nouveau en cela aux sénateurs assouline
qui m'avait posé cette question
je l'en remercie alors sur la
composition du collège je veux pas
sortir de ma modeste condition de
président d'une autorité gouvernement
fait des choix et le parlement bien
évidemment les souverains pour pour
décider de la delà de la bonne formule
[Musique]
je m'entends parfaitement ce que ce que
vous dites sur la nécessité de préserver
les équilibres
ça me paraît très très important au
regard d'un principe fondamental pour
notre institution qu'est le principe
d'indépendance
donc c'est très important que les
autorités de nomination soit diverses et
que de la même façon on essaie
renouvellement périodique ce qui fait
que c'est pas toujours les mêmes
l'autorité qui nomme au même moment et
du coup on a une diversité de profils et
de personnalités différentes
je redis devant vous puisque j'aime bien
sentir votre réflexion n'était pas
complètement abouti que je privilégierai
toujours un scénario à 7 plutôt qu'à a
plus ça je me permets d'insister sur ce
sur ce point il ya d'autres options
qu'on avait on aurait pu envisager un
jeu les évoque devant vous mais une fois
encore je ne peux pas sortir de ma de ma
condition qu'ils auraient pu préserver
le mode de nomination actuel qui aurait
consisté à dire que de façon successive
le président du sénat le président de
l'assemblée nationale
daisy périodiquement au titre de leur
droit de nomination actuelle un
magistrat si si si c'est le choix contre
voulais faire
ça pourrait être ça pourrait être une
option alors il faut que le président du
sénat le président de l'assemblée
nationale
ça serait un respect de leur pouvoir de
nomination tels qu'ils existent
quantitativement aujourd'hui et ça
répondrait en même temps cette sécurité
d'avoir toujours au sein de ce collège
nonobstant ces renouvellements au moins
un magistrat pour traiter de ces
questions là je raisonne je raisonne à
votre voix merci de votre propre au jeu
ces questions de déontologie des
programmes sont les questions les plus
les plus délicats sous entendez souvent
parlé devant vous puisque vous
m'interrogez régulièrement
monsieur le sénateur on a toujours cette
balance à opérer et on est très attentif
sur ce point entre la nécessaire liberté
d'expression je rappelle que nous sommes
les garants de la liberté de
communication c'est l'article quand
notre loi la loi qu'on met en oeuvre et
une loi de liberté s'appelle comme ça
loi relative à la liberté de
communication et l'état l'audiovisuel ce
que la loi de 1881 a été pour la pour la
presse écrite en contrepartie donc nous
devons protéger cette liberté nous
devons protéger le débat et il est
normal que le débat se fasse dans les
médias dans les médias audiovisuels
c'est leur vocation y compris au titre
du pluralisme tel qu'il est posé par la
loi et en même temps vous avez raison le
rappelait monsieur le sénateur il y a
des limites qui sont posés par cette loi
on ne peut pas tout dire à la télévision
ou à la radio
la loi a posé une série d'interdits
notamment les avait mentionné tout ce
qui attrait l'incitation à la haine ou à
la discrimination et je le dis ici très
très simplement le csa remplira remplira
son office chaque fois qu'il estimera
que ces principes posés par la loi
ces obligations qui incombent aux
éditeurs sont sont transgressées alors
c'est vrai que on le fait dans le cadre
de procédures qui sont qui sont qui sont
assez contraignante je ne cache pas
c'est sais pas c'est pas anormal en
réalité parce que comme on agit dans le
champ des libertés publiques
c'est quand même normal bien évidemment
que le justiciable d'une part des
garanties et que la procédure que non
que l'on mène donne toute sécurité avant
avant que l'autorité ne statue mais
c'est vrai que ça donne une mécanique
est assez lourd puisque on doit dans un
premier temps prononcé une mise en
demeure pour constaté un manquement et
dire à l'auditeur bon là voilà ce qui
s'est passé chez vous nous considérons
que c'est un manquement
et si un manquement de même nature se
perd chez vous eh bien nous rentrons
dans une procédure de sanction donc et
vous avez toujours un décalage
chronologique vous avez un fait qui se
produit mise en demeure
ensuite il faut attendre qu'il ya un
autre fait même nature qui se produise
pour que cette fois on saisissent un
rapporteur indépendant qui va instruire
à son rythme ensuite on n'auditionnait
partie qu'ensuite on délibère donc c'est
vrai qui s'écoule un certain temps alors
je crois que nous avons nous avons
quelques efforts à faire sur sur nous
mêmes on en parle régulièrement avec le
directeur général que dans les saisines
dont nous sommes l'objet
il faut probablement qu'on sache bien
pris mieux prioriser ce qu'on fait il ya
des manquements qui sont probablement
plus graves que d'autres qui nécessitent
une réponse plus rapide que que d'autres
il faut probablement dans notre dialogue
avec le rapporteur indépendant également
on puisse
essayez d'aller plus vite dans certains
cas le rapporteur le même longtemps
alors modifié modifier la loi
ce qui est très délicat c'est on a eu ce
débat avec le conseil d'état sur le
projet de loi à propos de à propos des
sanctions en cas de manquement aux
obligations de financement
c'était un principe constitutionnel qui
oblige d'avoir cette séquence de mise en
demeure distincte de la procédure de
sanction est donc le simple fait d'avoir
cette obligation c'est qu'on a
obligatoirement comme énoncé un certain
rythme dans la durée sur les sur les
vente de catalogues l'écouté bien
évidemment tout ce qui va dans le
renforcement de la protection de notre
notre patrimoine serait pas surpris que
je vous dis ça va dans le va dans le bon
sens et on imagine bien sûr favorable
alors après il faut trouver le juste
équilibre avec la liberté du commerce et
des opérateurs des opérateurs privés et
je crois que j'étais effectivement le
sens des principales de les observations
de du conseil d'état sur le sur le texte
[Musique]
on avait posé une question sur
l'opportunité d'instaurer des lignes
directrices t le sénateur maquis de
mémoire je ne sais pas s'il est encore
en ligne avec nous je pense qu'ils
voient là c'était sur la question des
listes noires en disant que voilà le
texte laissait beaucoup de latitude aux
régulateurs évoqué l'hypothèse de
prévoir le la possibilité d'émettre des
lignes directrices pour pourquoi pas ces
temps c'est une formule que le
législateur a utilisé à plusieurs
reprises
c'est le cas pour la loi un fox c'est le
cas sur la loi séparatistes pour la
lutte contre les contenus haineux
c'était le cas sur les violences
conjugales également à propos des la
protection des mineurs pour l'accès aux
sites pornographiques ou le régulateur
se voit confier la possibilité d'émettre
des recommandations
même des lignes directrices donc en tant
que tel je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
d'hostilité avec cette suggestion
madame la sénatrice morin desailly pense
avoir répondu en partie à vos questions
sur les moyens
je prends un exemple puisque vous êtes
très familière de la grande bretagne qui
est celui de love comme bon leur love
comme est un régulateur intégré donc qui
à la fois la compétence télécoms et la
compétence e audiovisuel mais cumulées
c'est un régulateur qui aujourd'hui doit
avoir de mémoire 850 collaborateurs à
peu près et j'ai constaté nous et nous
on est à 300 et la recette est à 166 ont
même si on avait fusionné avec leur
sapin on aurait été à 460 alors que
l'ofcom et à 850 donc un effet de taille
et et love comme vient d'annoncer il ya
très peu de temps qu'ils allaient encore
recruter une dizaine une dizaine d'âge
plusieurs dizaines d'agents tu leur
dédommagement
bon je ne suis pas dans ces inflations
et ses demandes qui serait contre nature
pour moi mais ça n'empêche que voilà on
va avoir besoin d'un certain renfort et
de la même façon puisque vous évoquez la
dimension européenne
incontestablement il faudra que les
regards auquel vous avez fait allusion
et son président actuel qui est mon
homologue allemand il y travaille
lui-même se renforce à partir du moment
où la réglementation européenne du ds
arrêt du dm en verra le jour je me sais
pas s'il verra le jour sur la présidence
française de l'union de l'année
prochaine mais c'est sûr que les regards
si les régulateurs nationaux sont amenés
à jouer un rôle important pour la mise
en oeuvre de cette de ces règlements
européens il faudra que les regarde lui
même se renforce et devienne
progressivement une forme d' agence
européenne pour assurer la coordination
de cette de cette régulation
le texte sur le ds a donc avance le les
regards à exprimer une première une
première position favorable sur le
principe plus critique sur la
gouvernance que prévoit le ds à vous
savez ce système pyramidal d'avoir dans
chaque pays un coordonnateur national
des oeufs des différentes autorités qui
lui-même se fédèrent dans un board
présidée par la commission bon voilà il
ya un travail de réflexion qui est en
cours là dessus
y compris au sein des autorités
françaises du côté de les regards pour
probablement faire faire évoluer cette
cette gouvernance qui ne semble pas tout
à fait optimale sur les avantages de la
tnt les avantages sont un bien
évidemment la couverture très large du
territoire 95% du territoire
la gratuité ce qui est quand même pas
négligeable par les temps qui courent
pour beaucoup de nos pour beaucoup de
nos concitoyens et d'avoir une capacité
une une offre une offre élargie
quoi quoi qu'on pense de telle ou telle
chaîne il ya une offre élargie sur la
tnt
aujourd'hui et puis l'anonymat puisqu'il
n'ya pas du tout de l'accès aux données
de l'usager comme c'est le cas à par
l'intermédiaire des boks notamment donc
là les données de son sont totalement
protégé puisqu'il ya pas de l'anonymat
complet du téléspectateur est une
possibilité de modernisation qui est pas
négligeable maintenant avec les
perspectives d'ultra haute définition et
puis cette norme technique que vous
mentionniez d'ailleurs dans votre
proposition de loi madame la sénatrice
la hbbtv qui permet d'avoir sur son
téléviseur tnt une forme d'interaction
et qui permettra dans l'expérimentation
étaient en cours avec arte par exemple
de se connecter directement à la
plateforme art et point fr en utilisant
son téléviseur normale en l'occurrence
le canal 77 donc on aura la chaîne arte
sur le canal 7 et la plateforme art et
point fr sur le canal 77 delà de la tnt
donc c'est un vrai plus qui est offert
qui est offert aux téléspectateurs
et il en sera de même pour pour la
plateforme pour la plateforme salto sur
lequel donc on a autorisé cette
expérimentation pour les six mois qui
viennent et on en tirera les
enseignements de cette de cette formule
mais c'est pour ça que si nous
paraissait intéressant si si le
parlement introduit les propositions
relatives à la modernisation de la tnt
dans le texte d'intégrer aussi cette
interactivité avec la norme hbbtv et que
les téléviseurs qui auront la norme hd
voilà soit puisse utiliser également la
norme hbbtv
alors madame la sénatrice darcos merci
de merci de votre question moi je vous
redis ma conviction je crois vraiment
cessé point central du texte c'est de
lutter contre contre les sites pirates
parce que c'est vraiment là le coeur le
coeur du sujet c'est vraiment là dessus
qu'il faut mettre le paquet hadopi a été
construit il ya dix ans autour du
piratage pair peer-to-peer commentaires
en bon français mais ça c'est le monde
d'avant si j'ai repris une expression
une expression à la mode
alors bien sûr et d'autre part la
riposte graduée ne
ne l'a sous-estimons pas totalement les
lettres tout de même que l'autorité
envoie quand vous regardez les chiffres
d'adp qui ne sont pas sans effet grosso
modo 70% des personnes qui reçoivent
c'est là que je cite c'est celle de
mémoire rebascule sur une offre une
offre légale et les chiffres d'adp aux
pistons ce point de vue la trt très
parlant donc moi je pense vraiment
important de focaliser notre énergie sur
sur les sites pirates
on a parlé de ce qui se passe en matière
de en matière de sport c'est vraiment là
qu'il faut qu'il faut taper ce que c'est
vraiment là que l'argent se fait donc on
est dans une activité sur laquelle il
faut il faut taper plus que d'aller
chercher le l'internaute je pense que
c'est plus efficace à mon sens me
demander mon avis dans le jeu je vous le
donne voilà avant il y avait une
deuxième question alors ça je suis moins
je sais pas s'il n'y sommes blancs
chaussettes pour répondre à la question
parce que là où je suis moins familier
sur ce deuxième point la sénatrice je ne
supporte plus nos plus grands experts
puisque comme le rappelait président
maistre sont des compétences qui
aujourd'hui sont exercées par pas par
l'hadopi ce que je comprends du texte
c'est que et de l'état que le droit
c'est que le code de la propriété
intellectuelle
organisme est de mise à disposition des
oeuvres littéraires ou non aux personnes
souffrant de ce handicap voilà sous
forme de fichiers numériques ils doivent
être déposés par les éditeurs auprès de
la bnf qui ensuite les met à ma
disposition de certains établissements
et le projet de loi prévoit de confier
alors comme un pouvoir de mise en
demeure des éditeurs pour qu'ils mettent
effectivement à disposition ce fichier
numérique de la bnf qui elle-même
ensuite le distribuera ou le mettre à
disposition de son côté des
bibliothèques et des médiathèques et de
tous les établissements qui sont agréés
pour pour ce faire
de marque ou aïd question féminin qui
m'a dit qu'il ya eu un problème de
connexion donc c'est pour ça qu'il
n'était pas à l'écran quand vous avez
répondu à sa question je vous remercie
monsieur le président pour tout cet
éclairage par contre j'aurais souhaité
que vous précisiez quel sera l'effectif
futur
avec la fusion hadopi csa et le budget
prévisionnel
voilà parce que vous en avez évoqué et
nous parler de budget dédié etc
mais j'aurais voulu avoir ces précisions
je vous remercie merci madame la
sénatrice alors donc le conseil
supérieur de visuels actuellement donc
ce 300 personnes hadopi c'est une
cinquantaine de personnes donc la fusion
des deux autorités on additionne 3 3 350
effectivement et nous gardons toutes les
équipes ce n'est pas en effet et sur
cette base de 350 on sera probablement
ameur a demandé qu'on peut rentrer
quelques créations d'emplois pour mieux
porter les compétences du point de vue
budgétaire
le csa
est un budget d'environ 37 millions
d'euros
on relève des services du premier
ministre pour le csa procès ça va la
hadopi donc en avant ou simple sénateur
à céline doit savoir sur le budget
d'hadopi 8,8 millions 8 mai à l'entente
de l'union voilà donc ça fera une
addition des deux donc 37 public
demandez vous
du coup ce sera aussi le premier
ministre vous serez sous la tutelle du
ministère de la culture je pense qu'on
restera rattaché au premier ministre
et donc dans le cadre de la préparation
de la loi de finances 2010 2022
on est en train de travailler mon
contrat mais affaire de demande de leurs
enfants parce que ce que vous ayez donc
pour le stand hallyday souligne parler
dans le micro au juste pourquoi tandis
que leurs collègues qui sont derrière
leur ordinateur
juste pour préciser donc donc pour
l'instant n'est envisagée que l'addition
de l'existant si vous demandez des
postes bien sûr vous allez demander plus
de moyens mais tout l'aspect
nouveau site etc externe n'a pas encore
été budgétés donc ses ventes
vous n'envisagez pas comme france
télévisions a dû le faire de réduire la
voilure pour pouvoir aux pierres plus de
missions à dire que je vous voyez ce que
je veux dire
et donc je vous réponds je n'envisage
pas donc en tout cas on va là on va
préparer nos demandes budgétaires dans
la perspective de la loi de finances
pour l'année prochaine et à partir du
socle que nous avons évoquées donc 350
emplois une masse budgétaire de l'ordre
de 45 nous on va redéfinir une maquette
twitter merci qui mirent plus de
questions merci monsieur le président
pour vos réponses toujours d'une grande
précision et bien entendu nous
commençons nos rafale le rapporteur et
la commission commence son travail
d'auditions je pense que nous manquons
pas d'ici le 18 mai de reprendre contact
avec vous et vos services pour
éventuellement approfondir certaines
pistes que nous merci beaucoup monsieur
le président merci beaucoup de la
pension vous portez à notre un autre
institution est extrêmement sensible je
l'exprimerai devant toutes les équipes
merci
[Musique]